.
SOMETHING WE AS CITIZENS ARE
OWED IN THIS DEBACLE.
F
FAREED IS GRIEVING THE LOSS OF
HIS MOM TO COVID RELATED ISSUES.
I KNOW YOU LOST YOUR MOM IN
INDIA EARLIER THIS YEAR.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WHAT IS GOING ON THERE IS
VERY REAL AND VERY PERSONAL FOR
YOU.
I WANT YOUR SENSE OF WHAT IS
GONE WRONG.
>> I THINK IT'S A COMPLICATED
QUESTION.
THERE ISN'T A SIMPLE ANSWER, BUT
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT
THE GOVERNMENT, PRIME MINISTER
MODI, INITIALLY OVER REACTED BY
WHICH I MEAN THE INITIAL L
LOCKDOWN WAS TOO HARSH, TOO
CRUEL, TO COMPLETE PARTICULARLY
WHEN COVID WAS NOT YET SPREADING
THAT WILDLY IN INDIA.
PERHAPS, AS A CONSEQUENCE OF
THAT, HE TOOK HIS FOOT OFF THE
PEDAL VERY QUICKLY.
THE REAL MISTAKE, IF THERE IS
ALESS A
L
LESSON TO BE DRAWN FROM THIS WAS
THE EXTRAORDINARY HUBERIS THAT
DEVELOPED AFTER THAT.
THE INDIAN GOVERNMENT DECLARING
VICTORY MUCH TOO SOON AND D
E
DECIDING INDIANS HAD SOME KIND
OF NATURAL IMMUNITY AND DECIDING
TO NOT ONLY CELEBRATE BUT ALSO
TO ALLOW MASSIVE GATHERINGS,
POLITICAL GATHERINGS, POLITICAL
RALLIES, ONCE YOU DO THAT,
REMEMBER INDIA IS A DEMOCRACY
WITH THE RULE OF LAW AND THAT
THEN BECOMES IMPOSSIBLE TO SHUT
DOWN OTHER KINDS OF GATHERINGS.
CRICKET MATCHES, THE RELIGIOUS
FESTIVALS.
ALL OF THAT CREATED A KIND OF
OUT OF CONTROL SITUATION.
YOU ADD TO THIS THE FACT THAT
THE INDIAN GOVERNMENT,
INDIA'S -- EVERY ONE KNOWS THE
DYNAMIC, FLOURISHING, ENERGETIC
PRIVATE SECTOR AND A
DYSFUNCTIONAL, WEAK, PUBLIC
SECTOR.
HERE IN A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS,
THE PUBLIC SECTOR HAS TO
PERFORM.
IT SIMPLY DID NOT, PERHAPS
CANNOT PU IT'S NOT BEEN WELL LED
BY PRIME MINISTER MODI.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, I'M GLAD
THE GOVERNMENT IS TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY BUT THEY NEED TO
DO MORE THAN TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY.
F
FRANKLY, PEOPLE SHOULD BE FIRED.
NEW PEOPLE SHOULD BE PUT IN
PLACE.
NONE OF THIS IS HAPPENING.
IT'S ESPECPISODIC.
U
YOU HAVE CHAOS IN INDIA AND THE
GOVERNMENT IS IN SHAMBLES.
>> I WANT TO TAKE OUR VIEWERS
BACK TO MARCH OF 2020, MARCH
24th.
INDIA'S PRIME MINISTER ORDERED
ALL, 1.3 BILLION PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY TO STAY AT HOME FOR
THREE WEEKS.
LET'S JUST LISTEN TO HIM
SPEAKING TO THE NATION.
>> TO SAVE THE COUNTRY, TO SAVE
EVERY CITIZEN OF INDIA, TO SAVE
YOU, TO SAVE YOUR FAMILY
MEMBERS, FROM MIDNIGHT IT WILL
BE A COMPLETE BAN ON MOVING OUT
OF YOUR HOMES.
EVERY STREET, EVERY DISTRICT,
EVERY LANE, EVERY VILLAGE WILL
BE UNDER LOCKDOWN.
>> IT WAS THE BIGGEST AND, AS I
UNDERSTAND IT, THE MOST SEVERE
ACTION UNDER TAKEN ANYWHERE TO
STOP THE SPREAD OF COVID.
FOR THE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS WHO
LIVE BELOW THE POVERTY LINE, FOR
THOSE WHO LIVE HAND MOUTH, THE
IMPACT WAS DEVASTATING.
WE REMEMBER THE IMAGES OF PEOPLE
LEAVING THE URBAN AREAS AND
DRIFTING HOME WITH THEIR GOODS
ON THEIR HEADS.
IT WAS SORT OF APOCOLYPTIC TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT BUT IT DID WORK.
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS THAT EVEN
IF THE GOVERNMENT WERE TO LOCK
DOWN ACROSS THE BOARD ON
NATIONWIDE BASIS AGAIN, YOU'RE
SAYING THAT WOULDN'T WORK AGAIN,
CORRECT?
THE IMPACT, THE ECONOMIC IMPACT
WOULD JUST BE TOO MUCH FOR SO
MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING IN A
DESTITUTE STATE ANY WAY, THEY
MUST WORK.
>> YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
HAVING BOTCHED THE FIRST
LOCKDOWN, THE MEMORIES ARE SO
BAD IT WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE TO DO
A SECOND.
THE FIRST LOCKDOWN WAS UTTERLY
DRACONIAN.
MOST PHARMACIES SHUT DOWN.
ALL PHARMACIES SHUT DOWN BECAUSE
THE GOVERNMENT DIDN'T
DISTINGUISH FOR A WHILE AS TO
WHAT WOULD STAY OPEN.
GROCERY STORES SHUT DOWN.
OVER 50 TO 100 MILLION MIGRANT
WORKERS WERE TRAPPED IN THE
PLACES THEY WORKED.
THE WHOLE THING WAS A FIASCO.
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN TELEGRAPHED.
THEY SHOULD HAVE SAID YOU GOT
FOUR DAYS.
THEY SHOULD HAVE MADE CLEAR WHAT
WAS OPEN AND WHAT WAS NOT.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, INDIA IS A
POOR COUNTRY.
IT DOESN'T HAVE MONEY FOR COVID
RELIEF.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE MONEY FOR
COVID LEAF, YOU HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL BE HOW DO A LOCK DOIN.
AT THIS POINT NOT ONLY WOULD THE
LOCKDOWN NOT BE ADHERED TO, THE
SITUATION IS SO OUT OF CONTROL,
IT'S NOT CLEAR YOU WOULD BE ABLE
TO MANAGE ONE AND PARTICULARLY
IN PLACES LIKE THE SLUMS OF
MUMBAI OR SLUMS OF CALCUTTA.
YOU HAVE POPULATION DENSITIES 30
TO 50 TIMES HIGHER THAN THAT OF
WESTERN CITIES.
TELLING PEOPLE WHO LIVE 15
PEOPLE IN TWO ROOMS THAT THEY
HAVE THE STAY INDOORS ISN'T
GOING TO STOP SPREAD.
>> WE SPOKE TO ONE JOURNALIST
WHO PENNED AN OP-ED FOR CNN AND
PART OF THAT, IN PART SHE WROTE,
IN INDIA NO ONE HAS APOLOGIZED.
NO ONE HAS RESIGNED.
NOTHING HAS CHANGED EXCEPT THE
INCREASING NUMBERS OF CASES AND
FATALITIES.
WHAT ABOUT SOME ACCOUNTABILITY
AT THIS POINT?
>> I THINK IT'S A VERY GOOD
POINT.
I WOULD POINT OUT,
UNFORTUNATELY, WHEN YOU GO BACK
DO A FEW MONTHS AGO WHEN THE
INDIAN GOVERNMENT WAS DECLARING
VICTORY, THE INDIAN MEDIA WAS
LARGELY COMPLICIT.
INDIA NO LONGER HAS A REAL FREE
PRESS IN THE SENSE IT HAD
HISTORICALLY HAD ONE.
MOST OF THE TELEVISION MEDIA,
THE LOCAL TELEVISION MEDIA IS
SLAVISHLY PRO-GOVERNMENT ACTING
A
AS CHEERLEADERS FOR PRIME
MINISTER MODI.
THE FEW THAT ARE NOT ARE
PERSECUTED AND HOUNDED WITH ALL
KINDS OF TAX CASES AND SUCH.
THE GOVERNMENT FELT VERY LITTLE
PRESSURE TO DO THINGS.
IT'S ACCUMED GREATER AND GREATER
POWERS FOR ITSELF WHICH SLZ O VZ
FURTHER CURTAILED THE INSIDE OF
THE MEDIA.
THE GOVERNMENT IS NOW TAKING
DOWNTOWN E DOWN TWITTER
ACCOUNTS, ASKING TWITTER TO
DELETE TWEETS, SAME WITH
FACEBOOK.
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IS AS THE
CRISIS GETS WORSE, RATHER THAN
THE GOVERNMENT DEMONSTRATING
GREATER COMPETENCE, IT'S
DEMONSTRATING GREATER
AUTHORITARIANISM.
>> FAREED, ON THE STORY.
YOU NOTED THAT INDIA E'S COURT
ORDERED THE GOVERNMENT TO
ADDRESS THE OXYGEN SHORTFALL BY
MIDNIGHT.
WE AWAIT TO SEE WHAT ACTION THE
GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY TAKES.
AS WE POINTED OUT, THE INDIA
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN VERY SLOW TO
RESPOND TO CRITICISM IN IT S
ACTIO
ACTIONS O